el pase sanitario se extiende por el
mundo en Francia ya es ley la exigencia
del documento que certifica que una
persona ha sido vacunada tiene una
prueba de covid negativa o sea
recuperado hace poco de la enfermedad
para entrar a varios lugares algunos
consideran que atenta contra las
libertades
la libertad no existe sin
responsabilidad la Libertad en la que no
le debo nada a nadie no existe es
ficción es una mentira que la gente se
dice a sí misma mi libertad solo termina
donde la libertad del otro empieza pero
sobre todas las cosas todo se basa en un
sentido de reciprocidad sin embargo este
tipo de medidas no es exclusiva del país
galo en Italia el 6 de agosto se
empezará a exigir un pase similar para
poder entrar a restaurantes museos y
estadios también en Israel comenzaron a
aplicar medidas parecidas desde marzo de
2021 el objetivo es el mismo incentivar
la vacunación
la regulaciones ya llegaron a América
donde el alcalde de la ciudad
estadounidense de Nueva York Bill de
Blasio anunció que la vacunación será
obligatoria para los trabajadores de
hospitales públicos y funcionarios del
ayuntamiento
necesitamos un acercamiento claro y cada
uno de nuestros trabajadores se tendrá
que vacunar o hacerse una prueba de
covid cada semana
en Argentina el gobernador de la
provincia de Buenos Aires Axel kissilof
había comunicado que a partir del 26 de
julio entraría en vigor el pase
sanitario que permitiría el aumento del
aforo en lugares como restaurantes para
personas vacunadas si bien la medida aún
no ha sido aprobada es una iniciativa
para contrarrestar el aumento de los
casos de Kobe 19 por las nuevas
variantes del virus